oh i wish this was just about dissolving
filler hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by karma and
we are back with part eight of our
review of jaclyn hills wellness journey
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor karma if you guys see an
influencer using a product online but
it's always sold out by the time you
check it out yourself you need karma in
your life so karma is a free mobile app
and chrome extension that allows you to
save money on the things you're already
buying with no additional effort from
you i actually used the karma extension
to save some money on my last middle of
the night sephora purchase so i now feel
much better about some of my more
frivolous unnecessary beauty buys but
it's also been a great way to save on
things that i really need like diapers
and food for the kids the way karma
works is that it scans the web for
coupon codes and applies them at
checkout immediately so basically you
just download the chrome extension and
visit over 50 000 stores to save the
products that you want then basically
karma looks for deals on your behalf so
you don't have to you'll instantly get a
notification in your email or phone when
an item that you've been looking at and
saved goes on sale has a relevant coupon
that you can use or comes back in stock
you can also organize your favorite
products in wishlist so that you can
shop more mindfully and avoid impulse
buys karma scans the web constantly for
coupon codes and applies them at
checkout automatically and this is a
special feature on your computer so the
chrome extension is a must you can also
earn cashback for you and to a good
cause when you shop from select retail
partners so that is another huge plus so
if you want to try out karma yourself
check out the link in my description to
download karma's chrome extension today
if you missed my most recent video of
jaclyn's wellness saga you can check
that out right here but today we're
gonna be taking a look at her march 14th
video dissolving all of my lip filler
and no this is not just about filler i
didn't think so as always pause the
screen or look at the description to
check on my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey also continuing with our
previous review of jaclyn we will be
discussing alcohol use disorder and
briefly mentioning suicide so i will
also be leaving resources down below in
the description if you need some
additional support also reminder that
i'm not a therapist or a substance abuse
expert so i will be speaking from the
perspective as a dietitian but if you're
not already subscribed hit that sub
button and follow me over on tick tock
and instagram abby's kitchen all right
without further ado let's get into it i
wanna drink so bad my skin is breaking
out i'm not losing weight
i'm tired i'm hungry and i'm doing too
much too soon i genuinely want to like
go back to my old ways today like i
seriously want just to cancel the day
and drink oh man i mean jaclyn has a lot
on her plate clearly it sounds like
she's back on her weight loss journey
and also trying to abstain from alcohol
without a more supportive coping
mechanism in place i mean
this is absolutely a recipe for burnout
and it sounds like jaclyn actually knows
that this is all too much too fast but i
also know that sometimes when you're
caught up in the momentum of a very busy
full life it can be very hard to kind of
grind it all to a halt to catch a breath
i hate this that's why i took the scale
out of the bathroom
i can't do this food thing i have to
wait it's just too much and how do i eat
all that cuban food the other night and
wake up a pound less i think i felt like
i was already so discouraged and then
when you started reading off all those
meals that's when i was like wanted to
kill myself cause i was like okay this
is horrible he was like trying to do
everything and i'm like stop and like
just focus on not drinking and throwing
some exercise i was like don't worry
about your diet we can do that when
you're when you feel like you've
overcome everything else okay trigger
warning for suicide mention um i don't
want to downplay the comment about
jaclyn killing herself over the meals
that she ate so if that was indeed an
indicator of her genuine mental state i
absolutely suggest seeking immediate
care so i'm going to be leaving some
self-harm resources down below but
judging by jordan's response i'm going
to assume that it was likely hyperbole
and just kind of move on to my
commentary on the food so in short food
and alcohol are two powerful coping
mechanisms that jaclyn uses and i'm not
sure we have evidence that we have a
strong enough strategy in the back
pocket to replace them quite yet also in
the past we've seen that you know even
minor setbacks on this arbitrary weight
loss journey tend to result in kind of
like a chaotic last supper eating yeah
i'm gonna eat pizza for the first time
in a really long time i'm gonna eat
whatever the hell i want i am so upset
sitting here eating pizza this is i feel
like the world's biggest failure as far
as my journey goes because i feel like
i'm just kind of right back to the past
so i'm about to eat pasta and i had a
piece of pizza
someone come stop me and i worry that
any perceived slip up with alcohol or
with food will jeopardize her progress
with the other so i agree with jordan
here the intentional weight loss should
100 percent be put on the back burner
the goal right now needs to be focusing
exclusively on healthy coping mechanisms
and behaviors that support jaclyn's
physical emotional and mental well-being
so sleep movement that feels good
adequate nourishment and therapy are all
key to helping establish a better
emotion regulation baseline i was just
angry that the scale went up i'm fine
with it staying the same i'm just angry
that it went up i'm telling you scales
fluctuate and they are the worst measure
of progress no more scale agreed and not
only are scales a not so great measure
of progress but it's totally normal for
our weight to fluctuate on a day-to-day
basis hormones medication meals water
retention bathroom habits bloating you
name it can all cause the scale to go up
and down five pounds or more so
preoccupation with a one pound increase
from one day to the next really tells us
nothing focusing on energy levels sleep
digestion or as her friend suggested
feeling good in your body may all be
more supportive tools in the toolbox
right now because if you're truly
feeling great emotionally and physically
then who the [ __ ] is the scale to tell
you otherwise it's time to take its
power away
as i did too much too fast i decided all
within a three-week period to cut back
drinking stop drinking alongside of
counting calories and working out it's
just it was a lot it's a lot to commit
to at one point in time um and i was
making myself crazy i was like
obsessively weighing myself dora and
full-on hit the scales so right now i am
just focusing 100 on only the drinking
aspect working out when i can and taking
it slower i also have been working so
much oh i am taking this week off of
work yes girl
yes so jaclyn is 100 on the right track
here and not only are certain foods and
alcohol and ineffective coping mechanism
to deal with her anxiety but the anxiety
can also physiologically impact the food
and drinking too so for example elevated
stress hormone levels like cortisol are
associated with increased weight
retention and appetite with one study
suggesting that stressed participants
burned 104 calories less from the same
meal compared to
non-stressed participants so it's very
possible that our body actually kind of
holds onto excess energy more
efficiently in periods of enhanced
stress so down regulating those stress
hormones with healthy coping strategies
may actually have a greater impact on
weight management than like cutting
calories could long-term going to cheat
just going to eat whatever i want even
though right now i'm focused 100 on a
drinking thing so it's not technically a
cheat but tonight i'm gonna have fun
i'll probably have like two drinks um
kind of like my reward trying to balance
out this relationship with alcohol the
best way that i know as i mentioned in
my previous review it sounds like jaclyn
is using the relapse prevention model to
address her drinking where the goal is
to reduce use or make it safer rather
than abstain completely so for jaclyn
this looks like having one or two drinks
in an occasional social environment
rather than like six to eight regularly
to cope with stress and it sounds like
this is working well for jacqueline
since her tolerance is already starting
to adjust to the more modest intake
however i do just want to flag the
language that she uses when describing
her relationship with alcohol as it's
not that dissimilar from her
relationship with food so for example
having a drink as a reward for
abstaining is basically the same idea as
having a cheat meal after a period of
restriction so my concern is that
putting alcohol on the same pedestal as
forbidden foods may keep it in a
powerful position to be abused in
stressful times so i would encourage
working towards neutralizing alcohol
rather than moralizing it as bad in some
scenarios and good or a reward in others
i'm on my period fully dressed but we've
seen a noticeable difference in the way
i
look like my tummy is way flatter keep
in mind i don't know i always go up like
a solid two pounds on my period oh my
god on average most folks can see a
solid two to five pound increase when on
their period thanks to the fluctuations
of progesterone and estrogen hormones
which can result in water retention
constipation and appetite changes
great
but another fun factoid is that the
progesterone levels actually have a
compensatory mechanism baked in place
that actually increases our metabolism
by up to 12 percent so your body kind of
has your back here and the weight on the
scale is really just water or waste
retention not excess fat that said i
thought jaclyn and jordan had agreed to
like put the weight loss journey on the
back burner so i don't know why he's
still putting her on the scale even if
it's a blind weight it does seem like a
counterproductive exercise to
participate in and encourage like what
is he going to do with that data what
behavior is that supposed to inform i
don't have to work this is the day that
i lay on the couch with a heating pad
and i just
drinked up my pain so i understand the
thinking that alcohol can help to numb
all feelings including period pain but
interestingly some research suggests
that chronic alcohol consumption may
actually make pms symptoms worse so
alcohol impacts estrogen testosterone
and luteinizing hormone which can
increase mood swings and cramps and
since it's also a diuretic the
dehydration can exacerbate period cramp
pain as well all the more reasons to try
to eventually cut back instead i'm going
to be eating chocolate
i'm going to try this thing from tick
tock with like the raspberries maybe
like the hazelnut and the raspberries
this is a raspberry with a hazelnut on
the inside and a tiny little dab of
nutella so i have a whole video on what
to eat on your period which i will link
to right here but there is actually a
scientific explanation for why we crave
things like chocolate and other
carbohydrate-rich foods during and
around our periods basically the sudden
drop in estrogen reduces our serotonin
levels which not only accounts for our
crabby moods i was sabotaged
by my baby box but it also can increase
our appetite this causes us to then
crave foods that help to increase our
serotonin production aka carbs it's also
worth noting that menstrual blood losses
can cause our iron levels to dip which
may also explain why we might crave iron
rich foods like dark chocolate so
pairing the chocolate with the raspberry
for some vitamin c is actually an
evidence-based choice because that
vitamin c can help to enhance the
non-heme iron absorption plus we're
getting some magnesium from the hazelnut
which can help to reduce uncomfortable
water retention and bloating during
menstruation so honestly i'm not sure i
would call any food a pms cure but if
it's satisfying for jaclyn it sounds
like a pretty period friendly and
delicious snack to me on sunday i was
like all right let's let loose it's the
first time that i will in like seven
weeks we were hammered i was so drunk my
tolerance has definitely gone down i'm
so over i'm so grossed out by alcohol i
never want to deal with that again i
never get hungover again so i'm happy to
hear jaclyn starting to rely less
heavily on alcohol so her body's
metabolism of alcohol is kind of
starting to recalibrate but i do want to
bring it back to how her relationship
with alcohol parallels her relationship
with food not only has alcohol shifted
from a coping mechanism to a reward but
i'm worried about the kind of binge
repent restrict pattern we just saw in
miami basically we're seeing her kind of
allow herself to indulge in this unique
situation because it's a special
occasion but then we saw her over
consumed to the point of throwing up and
then the next day swearing off all
alcohol forever there's a pattern here
people this is exactly how we've seen
things go down with her cheat day eating
in the past so i am 100 behind the
relapse prevention model and finding
ways to safely integrate alcohol into
one's life to break the unhealthy coping
mechanism but we also want to ensure
that we're not following into an all or
nothing mentality whether it's cheat day
for food or cheat day for booze i don't
think this is a healthy approach it
isn't teaching moderation or feel good
balance it's teaching your body to live
in a perpetual state of discomfort and i
fully understand that this is an
imperfect process and that jacqueline is
doing her absolute best to navigate with
the strategies that she has but i think
the goal right now should be working
with her therapist on a new viewpoint of
these vices that feels additive and
complementary in her life not like a
divisive tug of war we wish jacqueline
the best on her journey and we will
continue to follow what's next to come
so on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
karma for sponsoring if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what or who
you'd like to see your view next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]